well surprise surprise it seems like
Kamala Harris couldn't care less about
the Border even as vicious cartel
violence spills into America the vice
president out in Arizona pushing green
energy while ignoring the Border crisis
do you have any plans to visit the
Border in Arizona I've visited the
Border I will not on this trip but I I
have and I will again be on the border
that it is one of our highest priorities
to continue to work on making sure that
the border is secure
but one California sheriff is calling
out the mounting dangers of an open
border after a cartel-style massacre in
his community left six people dead
including a mother and her 10 month old
child I can tell you cartels are here
they are here for multiple reasons
selling drugs is lucrative there's a lot
of money to be made
the influence of these Mexican cartels
is now in dozens of cities across the
U.S and Republican congressmen are
turning to military force to fight them
on their home turf these Mexican drug
cartels have been around for a while but
the difference now is fentanyl this is
not a drug problem this is not a war on
drug problem this is a poisoning problem
and they're killing about 80 000
Americans a year and The Mexican
government does very little to thwart
this
judge so you know the sheriff says the
cartels are here that's been true for a
while the thing that I worry about is
this Mexican cartel style corruption
bleeding into communities in the U.S and
once that happens it's virtually
impossible to get rid of it well I think
that given the homicide that we saw the
massacres I should say of those six
people in Goshen California uh where
they shot a 17 year old mother and a
10-month-old son in the head and a
grandmother in bed and people running
away shooting them in a ditch I mean
it's clear that the the violence of the
cartels is here
um I can't imagine giving the Mexican
cartel areas of influence that we just
had up on the screen that
um the corruption and the money uh uh
you know the corruption the financial
corruption isn't already here look the
Biden Administration is singularly
responsible for this they have and
that's why it's so hysterical that
Kamala Harris says the border is one of
our highest priorities Kamala tell me
what have you done you haven't even told
us what the root cause is is if we
didn't already know what the root cause
was you know you got freebies show up
you know bring your family everything's
good
um and and the the Barb the medieval
kinds of uh violence that will uh that
go along with this cartel violence going
along with the financial corruption will
be the end of this country not just the
poisoning of people uh a hundred
thousand a year it'll double triple in
the next few years but uh Joe Biden's
good with it because he's not doing
anything and they've done they've
actually done things to make it worse by
suing States like Arizona Jesse and
telling them to take down their own
makeshift border walls but I find it
interesting when you have this
legislation introduced in Congress to go
after the Mexican cartels that the
Mexican Government gets quite
uncomfortable why is that because the
Mexican Government is the Mexican cartel
it's the same thing and you made a good
point about the violence spilling over
in the corruption spilling over the
violence and the threats work
with Mexican officials but the money in
the bribes work with American officials
and if you just shower U.S officials in
small towns and midtowns with cash
that's an easy way to get the fentanyl
in Faster I want to talk about
Commonwealth for a second you know when
you fly across the country on a business
trip and your cousin has happens to live
in the exact same city you're going and
you know it's the right thing to do to
call your cousin and say I'm in town
let's go have dinner
and you still don't do it and the next
night you're out of there on the flight
and you like I should have done that but
I didn't do it that's Kamala she flies
all the way across the country all the
way they say they care about jet fuel
you could just kill two birds with one
stone do the groundbreaking do the
Border trip and you're back by Friday
how can you not do that I was guilty of
it one time and I'm still distraught
over it I had a shoot at Sturgis the
bike rally in South Dakota
been there it was an hour away from
Rushmore
and I had the entire afternoon you
didn't go
well that was a mistake I got a massage
I got a massage and it was a terrible
massage it should have been it was a
terrible massage and uh it's probably a
once in a lifetime thing Mount Rushmore
I'm an hour away and then we're going to
be in South Dakota again maybe I will
but I regret it and Mount Rushmore is
her border you should you should um
Jessica you know there's a lot of talk
about comprehensive immigration reform
lots of different issues on illegal
immigration but when it comes to cartel
violence do you think Democrats could
get on board with this legislation that
targets them with cyber military on the
side I would think so I don't know
anyone who likes cartels
so and they're you know they don't when
they
medieval style chop up someone's head or
whatever they're not asking you know who
did you vote for in 2020 or something
like that right these are bipartisan
issues
um I think that any comprehensive plan
to address that and we have to admit
that President Biden was just at the
border and he did lay out a plan where
he has pushed the Mexican president to
make sure that people can still stay
there where if you're coming from
Central American countries that you have
to show proof that you didn't apply for
amnesty in other countries this isn't
like it's being completely neglected by
the administration I'm not saying that
they've solved all of these problems but
he was there three weeks ago she was
there in 2021 I get the cousin thing you
should have gone to Rushmore for sure
but you can take Jesse Jr but
it's really unfair to act as if there's
been complete neglect of this issue is
that fair I mean Biden went and it was
like a North Korean style propaganda
it was just a good day there it was a
dysfunctional marriage selfie on
Instagram when he went there they
cleaned the place up they took a picture
and smiled they left and it went back to
everyone going to their separate
bedrooms and just you know kill Mead
runs summer tours to Mount Rushmore so
maybe hit him up he's got a Fox Nation
special but
um I think the the thing with Kamala is
when they asked her that she pointed the
wrong way number one did you see her
nervous reaction yeah yeah no that's a
mountain that's Flagstaff thanks though
thanks for trying like they just
completely out of touch
she had her aunt well uh yeah I'm
planning on going but not now see we
gotta go it's like Bugs Bunny they had
to make a left in Albuquerque you know
because she really got to be somewhere
else she was there to do the whatever
little fancy pat on the back it was and
they do little shovels and high-five and
tell each other how they did a good job
and then lo and behold
the media is starting to turn and ask
her a question like that that I'm sure
was not cleared and she freaked out and
did what she I don't know what it is
with this Administration and no one
taking speech classes Jesse I took
speech in college I think everyone here
at one time I never took speech Kamala
and President Biden don't like making
speeches or saying clear things she
literally was like it's over there
that's not an answer yeah and you know
in Arizona you don't have to go to the
exact border to see the problem I8 and
I-10 or just to Phoenix and why is
fentanyl not considered an act of War if
they were pouring Agent Orange in our
water yeah would be doing something yeah
good point hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else